when you're presented with a script how
can you tell good writing versus bad
writing I mean there's there's writing
that maybe with a few more iterations
would be excellent and then there's
things that you know this just isn't
going to work has a really good question
a comedy as well is a very specific
thing because you know there are writers
that are really good at jokes you know
and can really you know they're just
really funny people but maybe sometimes
don't necessarily understand story you
know such the structure might be so you
might read something on the surface has
some really good beats but as a whole it
just doesn't do together so I think the
thing that I tend to look for first in
in any script yeah is a sense of story
does that you know does this person sort
of know the story that they're telling
and and you know did they understand the
sort of structure of things in ich and
again it's a sort of subtle thing that
you come to to see analysis also is a
story that that you know that I like I
mean that you know it's like anything
that there are films and scripts and
what-have-you that are not for everybody
so you know I can't
I'm a sort of no enjoy script but it's
not because it's not good maybe it's
just not I'm not the person for it but
but ya know I mean a story is definitely
a thing that I think most writers if
they can get a good handle on studying
that and understanding character and and
you know and motivations and I have you
that that's that's the sort of
foundation did Joe crying and stuff I
think you know if you can do that as
well and then you're on a good track but
it's really funny it's it's quite rare
to see people you can kind of straddle
both things
you